well let's get all the latest on what is
happening on the ground in Ukraine I'm
joined here at the screen by military
analyst Philip Ingram at hi again to you
Philip of course today as we're hearing
there from Aisha is Orthodox Christmas
uh in in the Russian calendar what do we
know about this so-called ceasefire
which President Putin has offered well
Orthodox Christmas Day Day 318 of
Vladimir Putin's 10-day military
operation
um according to UK defense intelligence
this morning there's been no real let up
in fighting along the front line and if
we get into the front line You'll back
moot that Village has been talked about
for weeks and weeks and weeks the
Russians have made some advances just to
the north of bakmud in Little Village of
solidar where they have captured
um the salt mines that are there and
that's literally just just to the north
of of the village itself something that
the Ukraine has been holding for quite
some time
um the Russians are trying to encircle
back to capture it the ukrainians are
effectively blocking them and fixing
them in place whilst the ukrainians then
look at advances and are pushing and
probing elsewhere and again UK defense
intelligence talks of
um in the village of cremina and to the
west of that in the forests there that's
the ukrainians are making some advances
forward and they're trying to look and
see if they can push through to this
Russian line of communication that there
is and then potentially threaten the
right flank of of bakmut
um as the Russians are are fixed in that
place so that's what's happening from a
tactical perspective all right and the
United States made uh what could be a
very significant announcement of further
military age didn't they last night tell
us about that they did another 3.75
billion dollars worth of aid but the
most significant bit are 50 of these
which is the Bradley infantry fighting
vehicle now the Bradley infantry
fighting vehicle is different to the
m113 battlefield taxis that that have
already been donated there's another 100
of those going in as well they will
allow troops to be taken up to the
fighting location but they then have to
get out and go and fight through it
because they're not protected enough to
attack through it whereas the Bradley
has got you can see the the 25
millimeter chain gun it's got machine
gun and it's got two two anti-tank
missiles and this has got the armor and
the fighting capability to fight through
any position destroy any Russian armored
vehicles including main battle tanks and
then allow the Infantry to Dismount and
fight back and clear the positions and
when will they reach Ukrainian soil no
time frame has been set yet but what
it's done is it stimulated
um and is on the back of European
announcements where the Germans have
announced they're going to donate up to
40 martyr infantry fighting vehicles and
the French have said that they're going
to give a number of number to be
confirmed AMX 10 wheel tanks so
Ukraine's ability to fight unarmored
battle is increasing okay well that
certainly uh it could be game changing
couldn't it as we go into the into The
Long Winter and what is the significance
of reports of Russian equipment and
troops going into Belarus yeah well
we've got Russian troops equipment going
into Belarus we've also had an
announcement that the Ukrainian Military
Intelligence said that Putin intends to
call up another 500 000 individuals over
over
um the January period uh belarusa the
threat from their splits
um the Ukrainian ability to carry out
offensive operations in the East and to
the north it's a great big border yeah
we have to look at that and therefore
it's too early to tell whether we're
looking at an attack from Belarus or
whether they're going for maskarovka a
bluff just trying to split and suggest
that they may come from there and stop
the ukrainians from concentrating their
defenses